Hey Jessica.
>> Hey Catherine.
>> I got these sketches from Andre,
do you want to check them out?
>> Sure.
>> What do you think?
>> Wow, they look really good.
>> Yeah.
>> Man, so I'm liking all of them.
But maybe we shouldn't
use this first one here.
>> Why not?
>> Well, in Android,
we generally don't like
using splash screens,
instead we jump directly
into the app content, so
that the user doesn't have to wait for
the splash screen to load.
>> Okay, how did you know that?
>> Well, it's covered in
the material design guidelines.
>> Yeah, Canola and I totally
covered that in the last course.
The students know that
spec front to back.
But knowing the spec is different
from actually applying it.
So I think we could really
use some design help.
>> Actually I'm glad you bring that up.
So I know this amazing
team of designers.
So they can take our ideas,
the features that we like, and
create some beautiful mocks for us.
>> That sounds amazing.
>> Yeah, so how about I'll
take these sketches to them.
>> Okay.
>> I'll get some mocks back and
meet with you later.
>> Okay, thanks.
>> All right, see you soon.
>> So, when you first open the app,
we see a list of categories, numbers,
family members, colors, and phrases.
If you click on the numbers category,
it shows a list of numbers.
And for the number one,
we have the English and Miwok words,
as well as an image and a button to
play the Miwok pronunciation aloud.
And the same applies for the family,
colors, and phrases categories.
So phrases, such as what's your name and
how are you feeling,
don't really have an intuitive
image to go along with them.
As a result,
we decided to show the English and
Miwok translations with the option
to play the sound as well.